what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I am doing
my first ever Q and A if we get 10 000
likes on this video I'll do another okay
I'll do another these questions were
submitted by the viewers yourself so
make sure you guys are subscribed to the
channel so you can submit questions if
we end up doing another okay so the
first question I would love to hear more
about your father and his General Life
advice and business advice it's
refreshing to hear a young woman who
genuinely admires her father so much so
my dad my dad's the coolest person I
know my dad doesn't drink he doesn't
smoke he doesn't have social media when
I quit my job and told him that I wanted
to be a YouTuber he was a bit shocked um
he but the one thing I love about my dad
is my dad is so supportive and ever
since I was a kid he always told me to
follow what you're passionate about and
he would tell me I don't care if you
make money selling toothpicks on the
side of the road do what you love
because you are going to work harder at
it than everybody else and that's like
the general strategy I've always had he
always still need to chase skills not
money and do what you like because
you're going to put in more hours than
everyone else he also said it can't be
about the money because you're gonna get
burnt out and it has to be something
that you genuinely enjoy doing because
you're going to be doing it for a very
long time and he always told me to put
money into coaching because it's really
important to have someone that knows
more than you do and that you're always
learning from so a lot of people are
afraid to get like pay a lot of money
for coaches or give up control of their
business to hire something out but my
dad is always the first to tell you to
like find whoever is the best at
something and learn from them or hire
them so that's my dad's business advice
and so I have one more I have one more
he also told me that any risks you want
to do in business to do it while you're
young because life changes and then you
have kids and a family and you just
never know how in the long run your life
is going to change and if you can afford
to make business risks so he said when
it's just you
um to take as many risks as you can what
do I think the dating world will look
like in 10 years it's gonna be a lot of
single mothers and a lot of people
living together not married I just think
there's going to be more men walking
away from Marriage I would hope that
there would be like a reset at some
point maybe it would go back to more
Traditional Values but I'm not hopeful
because I haven't seen any indication
that it's moving that way it seems to
have only gotten worse not better so you
know I hope that it wouldn't but that's
how I think it's gonna go what type of
music do you like I really like country
music I'm a big fan of Luke Combs and
Morgan Wallen I also like pop and hip
hop but like my favorite music is
definitely country I like Rihanna I
think she's really good in Beyonce too
Sam William how has your views of dating
changed from when you first started
dating until now what dating advice did
you get about boys when you first
started dating and you realized was
actually bad advice I would say I just
understand a lot more of the men's point
of view now so I think like a couple
years ago I just saw things from like
the woman's point of view and it's been
really interesting like learning how men
see things so for example
um one thing that I learned about guys
is that if a guy really likes a girl
like he doesn't want to tell everyone
like he kind of want to keeps it keep it
to himself we're women like if we really
like a guy we want to tell all our
friends about him and that's just one
like gender difference that I notice
what dating advice did you get about
boys when you first started dating and
you realized was bad advice
um okay I got the advice to like be who
you want to attract so if you want
something in someone to be that and it
kind of made me more of a tomboy and I
realized like men don't really want to
date the Tomboy they want to date the
cheerleader so that was one piece of
dating advice that I think was bad yeah
I just used to like kind of dress like a
bum all the time and that probably
didn't help Pearl I'd like to know why
the vast majority of single women voted
blue on Tuesday's election I'd like to
hear their reasoning I know you're in
the UK but you often talk about American
women too okay well I personally think
that it was because
can I say that I think that single woman
voted blue because of Roe versus Wade
happening right before the election and
I feel like these people want to get so
I think that's why you had more single
women turn out
um yeah that's it that's it that's all I
got what is your perfect Sunday Sundays
are my off day my perfect Sunday is when
I call my dad and he answers
um sometimes he doesn't answer I have
nine siblings so he's busy and then I
just like to sleep in and if I get to
play guitar that's cool and sing and if
I have time I'll go to church when I'm
alone in any public place Bar store Park
no woman pays attention to me they might
even think ugh another guy but once my
wife pops up and the other girls notice
this they purposely try to get attention
like they want to make my wife jealous
or catch me staring why do women do this
in general do they purposely want drama
um I think a lot of times like the
things that we as women do it's not like
conscious like I don't think they're
maliciously thinking let me take
attention away from your wife but I do
think that in female World it on some
level it's always a competition of who
can get the most attention so I think
like subconsciously women try to get the
most attention from men and also if you
you're with a girl it shows to other
women that you can get women and that
makes you more attractive I know this
isn't like a fun reality about female
nature it just kind of is how it is what
would you tell your 18 year old self
just pearly things
um don't work that sales job don't sell
copiers for two years that is a waste of
your time don't do that pursue YouTube
instead or social media do not sell
copiers for two years if you marry a
high value man would you give him
permission to have sex with other women
if he's emotionally invested in you
permission I want to give him permission
but I I think if you get a high value
man if you if you choose to marry if I
chose to go down the path of high value
man then that would also be signing up
for high value problems so if I chose to
go down that path I would know that it's
a possibility and I don't think I would
want to ruin an entire family over that
so what would I give him permission no
but if it happened am I gonna break up
my whole home probably not but I will
say My Views have changed on that
because that's a very hard pill to
swallow but the one thing you have to
know as a girl it's like if you choose
that guy then just know that might come
with it personal question to Pearl since
you are the next thing on YouTube how
has the dating game been different for
you it's been it's got to be hard
finding a real one it was probably
easier when you weren't the shiz I would
say the hardest thing about dating when
you're bigger is like okay if I go on a
date with someone and you know
everything about me already it's just
kind of awkward like okay it's different
if we both have followings because then
I can equally creep on you the same way
you can creep on me but if I go on a
date and you're like oh like I see the
cough coffee now you drink coffee every
morning and your coffee thoughts it's
like
I I know it's not creepy because I put
it on the internet but it feels like
that so I would say that's the that's
the main thing like it's different if
you're both in that position because
then you can it's kind of like equal
playing field but I don't know when it's
just one-sided it's kind of hard do you
know of any of the girls who you have
spoken with have actually taken your
advice I really try not to give advice
on the channel because I think every
person's different and I can't tell you
how to live your life I will say I do
think that some of the girls that have
been on their the channel see the world
differently and I know for a fact like
girls that are closer to me definitely
understand the men's point of view a lot
more and that's my main goal for the
channel is to have women understand the
men's point of view because I think life
is a lot easier when you can understand
the other sex and understand where
they're coming from and us as women like
men have always had to understand where
we're coming from in order to get laid
or get in a relationship but like women
don't have to do that so I just think
life is easier when you understand where
people are coming from what difference
do you see and observe between people in
the UK and those in the U.S okay I've
said this before I think that UK people
dress better I will say I've heard it's
similar in New York I just think UK
people are a bit more trendy
um I also will say I do think UK people
are slightly classier than us people
like they might be doing the same thing
that U.S people are but they're not as
upfront about it but I I've also said
that I forget I'm in the UK sometimes
because it's so similar to the US like
once you're in the west you're in the
west how to convince my wife what you
say without being conceived as you know
roll out to masi is a saying that's you
can red pill women but do you really
want to all you can do is tell her the
truth and if she takes it she does if
she doesn't she doesn't I don't think
that women have to believe all these
things in order for you to have a
relationship with them like most women
if they like a guy enough will just stop
talking about things they disagree with
them on you know you disagree
they're like it's like the Raging
feminist is like I'll never submit to a
man but she's cooking she's cooking for
someone at 9 00 a.m she's cooking she's
in the kitchen doing whatever he says
well guys let me know if you have any
other questions that you'd want to do in
the next q a if we get 10 000 likes on
this video I will do another so make
sure you like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and we will
talk to you next time as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible